and one of the things that has changed
biology is that things like sequencing
are actually accelerating faster so we
can now read the genomes of organisms
faster and cheaper net that the rate is
going up and the cost is going down down
down so we're starting to understand
biology at a deeper level because we can
see into the genomics and now we have
technologies like CRISPR that have gone
on top of many other previous gene
editing tech so we can be putting in
editing with genomes seeing what effect
it has putting in new functions into
organisms all these things that we just
couldn't do you know ten years ago at a
rate that was allowing researchers to
test many hypotheses over the course of
their career and also had a scale that
it could be global and every lab to do
it basically yeah what walk us through
sequencing itself so if I give a saliva
sample how do they actually sequence it
so I'm not an expert than any Gritty of
it so there's you know right now a few
different technologies like Ion Torrent
and Illumina sequencing or just by far
the leader in the space yeah so these
guys you know have machines all over the
world and you're sending samples to them
and they're setting you you know these
large data sets that we can now process
using machine learning and so I think
using machine learning applying that to
these huge data sets is what's really
I'm going to be transformative because
we can understand the genetic sequence
of many organisms and be comparing and
contrasting and actually seeing how that
genotype is relating to phenotype which
is the function that we see in the world
the expression yeah actually that's
really important how genotype and
phenotype are related how it actually
expresses itself into the world because
there are very similar ways that genes
express themselves in this world then
there are also different ways the
biggest immerse themselves into the
world based on their environments yeah
epigenetics exactly
genetics and one of the things you know
there's a big talk about you know doing
gene editing in humans that's like a
very controversial subject
yeah and it's happening in certain
diseases where it's a very simple you
know one mutation is leading to one
disease but as we start to understand
the complexity like sickle cell anemia
is yeah that's one example what that's
one gene that's causing the mutation and
the red blood cells in the Cystic
Fibrosis is another example there's
actually a company that went through
Indy bio that's working on FA P which is
an inherited disease in the gut
that leads to colon cancer and
essentially everyone who has it so one
mutation you can do a very simple swap
and edit but then what's really going to
be transformative is when we can start
to understand how many many different
genes interact with each other to do
much more complex things in the human
body so it's not just one mutation one
disease but many inter woven things are
genetic genetics that are causing some
sort of feature in a human or organism
that will be more difficult for sure
when there's multiple genes that are
being expressed they're causing the
mutations and then we have to try and
solve that or figure that out okay so
that was a little bit on sequencing
maybe we touch a bit on technologies
like CRISPR Cass 9 and then we'll dive
into a lot of the different uses and
companies so yeah tell us a little bit
about this was it last year or was it
2016 that the first discovery yeah um I
think it's actually a couple more years
than that it's been I think Jennifer
down and her lab published a few really
seminal papers around 2014-2015 so maybe
a little over two years though the
research has been kind of building to
get to a tipping point I think but you
know it's not the first gene editing
technology we've had I think just the
how fine the accuracy of it is something
that we haven't quite seen before and
the cost it's actually you know really
economical and can be done and you know
these proteins and reagents are very
simple so it can be done
basically any lab you don't have to just
be an MIT Harvard Berkeley level budget
to do so
but I'm so huge yeah it's a really big
deal because you have great scientists
all over the world who've long been
constrained by tools who that constraint
is kind of coming off and they have all
these hypotheses that they want to test
yeah all the creativity is going out
into the world I think that's something
we science is a very creative outlet so
to speak so you know people going back
to what I said before on in previous
years the life of a scientist the number
of hypotheses you could test and say a
40 year career was much more limited
than it is now so if you give a
scientist 10 X or more the opportunity
to learn and test yeah they just the
body of knowledge grows so quickly it'd
be like once we get to the point where
we can get into space ambassdor and test
all the different space hypotheses as
well and that would be also very
exciting time mmm same thing about the
brain and oh man it's it's a it's a
crucial equipped scientists with the
tools that enables them to test
hypotheses faster yeah yeah oh please
yeah go ahead they're just gonna say the
tools part is a really overlooked
because it's kind of the least sexy part
of an interesting and you know people
want to talk about you know you know
lab-grown meat and things like that
which are really exciting but the
fundamental tools that we need to
accelerate our oftentimes not as talked
about and not as exciting but really
transformative yeah that's that's a huge
takeaway we need to hone in on providing
artists and scientists and creators with
these tools that enable them to tinker
and that's we're actually gonna have
Josiah saner on later who's a big into
being kind of a guinea pig for genetic
engineering on himself
and so that and he has a whole kit via
the oden tons of kits so that's that's
exactly the tools that are needed and
investing in oh that's not as yeah sexy
as what's actually the quickly
applicable to people's lives so okay so
let's talk about CRISPR cast nine let's
talk about what exactly occurs to the
sequence let's say we see a mutation for
sickle cell anemia is there a way or
cystic fibrosis there a way to
Equipe is it we're equipping the protein
with the code to be able to go and snap
that out and replace it so it's not
doing the replacing it's doing the
cutting function and then when you put a
bunch of strands of the DNA in it but
when the DNA starts transiently being
repaired those new strands of the
healthy gene will be integrated into the
genome so the CRISPR cast lie does the
cutting has a guide RNA yet to match it
exactly match it and then it cuts it to
leave that new new place open for
healthy DNA and the healthy DNA just
comes naturally from the body well most
of the time we'll be adding that as well
so if the body has an inherent mutation
if you add the DNA in along with the
CRISPR cast time and then work itself
into the new DNA okay
essentially cool so the CRISPR cast
lines about the cutting in the right
place yeah the guide RNA exactly okay
cool okay all right so you guys have
works as understanding the code of life
now you're at 81 companies that you guys
have accelerated into this world over
three years I've had the amazing
opportunity to work with a couple of
them it's been so fun it's like really
helping scientists understand you know
business and bringing their products and
services to the world and that's a
that's an amazing thing that is really
important and empowering to do so I mean
you guys range across so many subjects
and we have a huge list to go through
but let's start with you talking about
some of the favorites ooh that's all but
with a platform in a while that's not
your thing it's easy to go to some some
of the recent ones that have been in the
press a lot Memphis meats is one that
comes to mind very easily because
they're in the news probably more than
yeah any other biotech company
yeah growing chicken beef pork and duck
in the lab using stem cells and recently
invested in by Bill Gates Richard
Branson Cargill Tyson yes dfj a lot of
these big names yes so I think for them
it's really exciting because it's
transformational yeah in the food space
which particularly in America with
factory farming has been getting a lot
of attention a lot of press the ethics
environmental concerns the health
concerns for individuals um so that's a
really big deal on how do we transform
an entire industry that has a lot of
momentum going for it yeah we just had
Stu's ever and on the vodcast who is
speaking about how it's a caterpillar
that's turning into a butterfly right
now yeah the food industry has all these
little colas and McDonald's and stuff
like that that's about to evolve into
the butterfly of what biotech can help
provide us with so okay so there's
actually you guys have a ridiculous
amount of clean meat clean dairy clean
egg companies and under your belt so
let's walk let's walk through this just
a little bit more so how rather than
raising a chicken and feeding it corn or
grass-fed however it ends up being fed
and being you know maybe locked up into
smaller compartments and being filled
with growth hormones that accelerate its
growth and then it was going through the
whole slaughtering process and packaging
process and shipping to the center and
then you going and buying it from the
grocery store now it's taking a feather
from the chicken and then being able to
use the stem cell from the chickens
feather - is it a collagen matrix what
in and then how does the stem cell turn
into a chicken breast mm-hmm so we're
looking at muscle biopsies of these
different animals finding really healthy
cells that are in you know just some
sort of muscle tissue got it um then
whether it's also another company of
those fish Calton
or Memphis means doing it for these yes
animal yes
you know we're putting it in cell
culture so we're putting cells and
giving them all the nutrients in the
space they need to divide and what in
flourish are the nutrients that they
need so there is what's been used right
now as one of the big drivers in the
growth media along with you know the
sugars and other things like that is a
fetal bovine growth serum you don't
bovine growth serum yeah so that's still
an animal product and what will
eventually be a fair a completely non
animal process so that means fetal like
fetus or like baby cows essentially it's
a very expensive thing interest and most
of the companies are now moving beyond
doing that so having other completely
non and more related imperatives to the
growth media so it's giving them all the
nutrients as well as the signaling to
divide so this is one of the big
challenges yeah actually getting that
cost down because it's very expensive
because they only have very small
amounts so that's one of the big
challenges and the other one is actually
creating structure yeah so it's easy and
the early iterations
I'll Memphis meets got famous was
actually a meatball so it's a bunch of
the cells you put them together with
some fat then you can cook it taste it
looks like a meatball but making a
chicken or a duck breast has the added
challenge of the fibers which is where
these companies are right now working
and making a progress on the fibers
what's more different than making the
meatball itself okay yeah so you're
giving the cells structure to grow in a
room yeah
okay so one part of it is doing the sell
agriculture where you provide the
nutrients that the cell needs to divide
and replicate and make more and then the
other part is the structuring of what
that actually ends up looking like oh
you know and okay so you listen Memphis
means finless foods now so we got a
we're working in the fish and the oat
and the oceans as well and making sure
that we don't that or that we do use a
biotechnology for growing fish as food
then we have Claire foods as well yep
you don't talk about them maybe a bit
sure they're a slightly different model
so they're an egg whites without the
chicken so no eggs having to extract the
egg whites um which is really really
water inefficient process
Arturo their CEO I recently found out
from him it's 2,000 liters of water to
get a 12 foot a carton of eggs which is
incredible
damn yeah really incredible so what
these guys are doing is a little bit
different than those other companies
there's a number of vinyl proteins that
make up an egg white to give it the the
protein concentration at the texture the
look the feel and they're taking the
genes that encode those proteins and
putting them in yeast and they brew them
and what essentially looks like a micro
brewery these large fermenters yes then
you get the proteins out and you can add
them together and recreate an egg white
and what's interesting is they're
individual proteins that have a ton of
applications and food and they're also
when you can adjust the concept the
ratio of proteins you could get an egg
white with the higher protein content or
that maybe it's slightly better for
bakery applications because it fluff
fluffs a little bit better gives a
better texture Wow
yeah you can start being in control of
the concentration of the actual egg
white that enables different uses
exactly so rather than taking the whole
egg and saying we want
vital proteins and then throwing out the
rest which is a really wasteful
inefficient process we're just creating
exactly what we want and designing
basically our food in biology yes what
are some of the other clean meat clean a
clean dairy the ones that you want to
share and then we'll move on if any in
the general food space similar to these
guys gel tour is a really exciting
company their engineering bacteria to
make different proteins
starting with collagen and collagen is
one that it's something it's in a ton of
foods we don't really think about how we
get it but it's basically the remnants
of animals being put in acid baths and
then the collagen kind of and somewhat
melts off of their tissue and then we
scoop that out to make this protein
really yeah not a process you want to
actually look at so they're able to
basically again put the genes that
encode this protein into bacteria and
similarly using big fermenters basically
brew collagen so to speak Wow and they
can also you know make customized types
of collagen for different texturing
effects maybe take a collagen that's
very rare and hard to find in nature
which then increases the price and makes
it very scarce and products and foods
and make it a much more stable supply
chain and much higher purity as well so
cosmetics research and development food
all these applications because we use
collagen for many many things you're
just seeing how back for jail tour
bacteria is being used for the
fermentation and then for Eclair foods
yeast is being used for the fermentation
and what's what how do you pick between
those for the fermentation process so
there's some nuance to it for for gel
tour for example it actually came out of
two scientists out of Princeton they
were doing the research on the certain
strain of bacteria and they found really
interesting switches that would shift
the focus of energy from division to
protein production so rather than
putting 90 percent of their energy into
making multiple cells they're putting 90
percent of their energy into making this
protein so they actually had certain
strains that they've been working on for
years and years but they knew how to
tinker with the genetics to make a more
energy-efficient words for the yeast it
was a matter of transforming them and
finding them to be a good vector to
express the protein so it was a bit of
expertise as well from the founders eye
okay that's a good breath of clean meat
clean dairy clean egg that's awesome and
it's so applicable to our lives it's
right away something that we do three
times a day usually that is impacting so
many animals across the world and people
that eat across well it's gonna be
something that's right around the corner
I mean that one's super soon being able
to sustainably feed the world cheap
protein and clean meat
yep all Shapiro's book clean meats
really good he's amazing yeah he's about
to be on as well he'll be around March
if it is but he's a great guy he's so
global yeah exactly
you shouldn't have many bio to do we've
met him a couple times yeah jail tour
did you see the the announcement they
had they actually using that collagen
they made a leather an animal-free
leather binding for one of his wheat
copies of his book because that was gel
tour that did that yeah I said that and
I really like that that was gel tour
yeah and they offer they auctioned it
for charity exactly okay
now that you bring that up we totally
need to talk about this as well
yeah so we're talking about using a
different mediums for example mushrooms
mycelium to grow structural materials
potentially actual like materials for
housing or potentially materials like
leathers so walk us down that yes
Michael works is an amazing company I'm
Phil Ross the CEO and I think one of the
inventors of this whole methodology of
making Michael textures and leather and
construction material what's amazing
about them is they're taking
agricultural waste products so things
that farmers are paying people to take
away or not knowing what to do with and
they're putting the spores of a mushroom
in and they can bind all these things
together and then they're giving it
different textures different thicknesses
and properties so you know Phil I
believe has made furniture and
construction materials but mace and
found that you know leather is this huge
industry again involving a lot of animal
throughput to get you know this material
that we use for so many different goods
and also the time and energy and
resources yeah I think it takes roughly
three years to grow a cow to the size
that were harvesting the hides well last
I talked to them it was two weeks to
grow an equivalent amount of this
mushroom leather which is amazing huge
difference to change and you know it's
an eco-friendly process you can you know
closed-loop so at the end you have
agricultural waste and mushrooms
yeah which are things that you know
exactly don't stick around for a million
years like styrofoam yeah or something
yeah and they can put different textures
in different colors that's a look the
feel of leather so it's like recreating
it if not making it even better I
remember first getting my hands on the
micro works leather and I just was like
mind was blown because I couldn't held
the dip yeah exactly so cool to be at
that moment of like whoa it's already
here in my hands
it's because of brilliant people working
together and coming up with these ways
to leverage biology and design so yeah
that one seems like it's also good right
around the corner in terms of impacting
people because we purchase things that
have leather and we use structural
materials all the time okay so that's
I'm glad that you brought that one out
that's a really important one okay so
maybe we touch on catalog next this is
really interesting we have so many
servers and database data centers that
are just constantly churning out
electricity and and all the equipment
that's actually being used to house all
that data and now we can store
we've been prying to figure this out how
to efficiently do it but storing the
digital zeros and ones in AST c's and
g's and then being able to have like
just a little tiny bit of is it what DNA
in the form of in the form of what so
it's I think the term is it's a
dehydrating laughs lies down so it can
store for longer you put it in a like a
minus eighty freezer essentially to
catalog it's a great company to bring up
because it's not thought of this way but
it's in a sense it's a biomaterials
company we're replacing silicon and hard
drives with DNA at this material that's
in all of us and it's you know a key
part of life and making it vastly more
efficient DNA I think is a million times
more data dense than any technologies we
have now for a CEO
incredible like you said it fits into
this tiny test tube it's basically free
to replicate using PCR yeah a pretty
standard technique in the lab
and it lasts for you know tens to
hundreds of thousands of years Wow
we've recovered DNA from you know
animals who are you know frozen and
Siberia for example there just have long
longer than gone
so rather than building these huge
server farms essentially sometimes on
the side of a mountain um that we have
to replace each server 20 every 20 30
years because they wear out you have DNA
you make as many copies as you like
essentially and put it in a freezer and
you can put that that huge data server
into one to three test tubes yeah
essentially the whole Library of
Congress into a couple of test tubes and
exactly is that up and keep that and
being able to what put is the actual
liquid that's in the test tube or what
is the DNA that's in the test tube
mm-hmm so it's DNA that's been encoded
if you think of a TCG it's like what is
the actual like liquid what's like the
molecules what is that what is there so
you have DNA that's been a I think the
exact process I'm not 100% sure on but I
think it's been like dehydrated down to
a more stable form that can then be
frozen so okay so it's actual just DNA
it's not like it's not like coding
something else with so they they encode
it and then they go through the process
of putting it to storage
so they can code it under normal
conditions and they're working on
different techniques to make it more
scalable and more efficient yeah because
right now while they're at Indy bio they
encoded one megabyte of information I'm
but to do a terabyte gigabyte or
petabyte you you need automation that
can go at a very large scale yeah
because we're creating so much
information right
the world yeah at a rate you know so big
yeah it's like though was it the last in
the last two years there's been I
believe in 90% of all data's been
created in the last two years
and that just keeps happening year after
you that's what yeah you trend is
something along those lines which is and
from what I understand like we are
actually gonna run out of silicon in
2030 you know forty years at the rate
that we're using it to build these
electronic devices think about you know
we started the vodcasts and think about
how much space this takes up with
YouTube yeah so yeah looking yeah
looking at long-term storage first you
know this data that we don't have to you
know read read every other day or every
month but something that companies are
backing up their information with that
they're required to do you know for 20
30 years or longer this is you know a
very safe way to do that and starting
with that kind of long game first and
then probably finding other methods to
do shorter term storage yeah and this
also reminds me of the seed vault in
Norway as well I'm not I don't know much
about their they they just put another
there 13 million dollars into the seed
vault which is I think in the side of a
large mountain or it's underground one
of those too but they are taking seeds
from around the world and storing them
in the seed vault just in case of
something okay yeah and I am thinking
that this is probably a pretty good idea
in the hole just in case idea of things
especially to be able to quickly
revitalize and restart humanity in the
drastic case that something does happen
but it kind of reminds me of that
because you can do the same thing with
DNA so it's dehydrated DNA inside of the
tubes now interesting what you mentioned
you know it made me think of the long
now foundation yes is one of those
amazing organizations that's thinking
about the long term of encode keeping a
record of every you know language that
humanity has some more and more people
I'm really inspired to see people
thinking long term and thinking about
how do we keep the richness of life on
diversity keep records of it yes yes
it's something crazy like there have
been 100 million species on the planet
but only 10 million are left really so
90 million species have died I've come
and gone have come and gone yeah come
and gone yeah I'd imagine most of those
are probably unlike organisms that we on
never would have even know yeah yeah and
I think a lot long now is also really
interesting because when do we ever
think about things past the length of a
human lifetime it's really important to
do so mmm similar to how we view things
and this is also really important for
indie bio and maybe to something that we
can help the new batches that come into
the accelerator understand but as much
as they're thinking down at the level of
the molecules and the DNA and the cells
that's amazing to be able to understand
that level that really small level and
then there's the really huge level of
like the cosmos and even our solar
system right so there's that level of
massiveness 93 million miles to the star
things like that
and then there's like kind of like the
in-between which is the human yeah it's
kind of like him between those two
things and so just being able to like
run that story by people to get them
like yes the small is really important
the massive is really important and so
our so we're us at this level but we got
to kind of at least understand these
other two massive and small and then
that also that reminds me of the long
now of the 10,000 year thing because we
have to both know about the you know the
past of civilization and in the present
moment that we live in and you know we
just had to simmer men on he was talking
abouts mileage and that like raises your
vibes which is smile is just like smile
more often and you'll you'll be a little
better yeah yeah and you'll help others
feel better just by smiling and stuff
like that so that really helps the
present moment and then also thinking
past the 100 year life expectancy of
this body you know what's what's what
society gonna be like in a thousand
years or even ten thousand years and
then that whole like ten thousand year
clocks like yeah we probably shouldn't
be using the finite resources on this
planet because it's gonna [ __ ] run
out yep things like that and so it
really helps us waken and they're right
here in San Francisco yeah and you know
thinking along the finite resources a
lot of things we think are renewable and
in a sense for our lifetime art so one
is you know old-growth trees like most
large trees take hundreds of years if
not longer we have this amazing company
right now she called Ling Grove which is
using getting rid of trees using flax
illan and a bio resin to make wood
composites for Sporting Goods musical
instruments scaling to construction and
furniture handling for cars places where
people want wood they love the fuel the
aesthetic yeah because it's very human
and natural but we don't have
that material anymore we've cut down so
much of our of these resources thinking
that I can plant a tree and I'll be back
but it's for us for our lifetime it's
it's not that way actually for those
massive ones that takes hundred years to
narrow that out and so you're
interestingly enough you can point it
and not only like the aesthetics of wood
but you pointed out kind of like the
daily uses of the mcgaven like a
baseball bat or a cricket bat or
something like that is even made of wood
so what did you say it was flax linen
the linen so we grow tons of flax seed
like in Europe and Canada is it
efficient to grow flax seeds yeah
relative to treat it's actually quite
efficient oh yeah mostly harvest for the
seeds as opposed to the linen and the
structure of it yes we have all this
material that can be used for something
else if you just think of new processes
to use it and with the composites this
company's been able to make the
stiffness to weight ratio which is why a
tree can be so skinny but so tall yeah
it's as good if not better than many
trees so it has performance superiority
as well essentially yeah ha so when
you're making an arrow or a paddleboard
it both looks great but also performs
the way you need it to it's so
interesting what's the company called
yin Ling Grove Lin Grove yeah Lin Grove
cool that's a--that's a good one mm-hmm
that's it good I love where all these
mines are just coming from what just
thinking about sustainability and the
future and just I don't think I could
have the the I'd have to do you get into
biology and get into sustainability for
such a long period of time to come up
with one of these moments these Eureka
moments for me to go into a field and
solve something like that Ron I have a
question for you
you know what would you eat a burger
that's clean meat that's grown from
cells grown celery culture I'm still on
the egg whites without yeah it's a good
one huh sure 2,000 liters of water for
12 of them 12 eggs well he dressed
[Music]
you know I feel like people that care
about animals care about the world kind
of are at least interested in trying and
figuring that part out and so you would
get you would give it at the egg white
to go to start and yes
yeah me too a video of what they do
the male chicks they grind them up you
know when to make the eggs they just
grind them up whatever no use to the
English and I was asked you know what
can you do about this and my only answer
was
yeah then first I can do
yeah yeah yeah and I guess even
sustainably speaking can have grass fed
pastures of chickens that are not but
we're still eating their eggs but
interesting to hear you know Ron and I'd
be interested here so many other you
know you guys at home just chime on in
let us know what you think
would you eat clean meat meat that
screwing from cells whether it's beef or
chicken or eggs or dairy or whatever
would you we'd love to hear about it and
maybe if you've had an experience with
it already even further talk about it
why would you why would you not see how
we've covered so much would you purchase
leather that's grown from mushrooms or
would you purchase structural material
that's growing from mushrooms yeah
there's so much storing the digital
dating DNA we've cut we've covered a lot
so what yeah well I do want to add to
that um around you know what can what
can I do what can the individual do I
think there's a lot of hilarity people
think why I do my thing or I go all the
way to the other end of the spectrum and
really these these big companies are
getting involved in the Memphis meats of
the world the Clara foods of the world
be plant-based food companies like not
Coe because they see consumers are you
know some people are going cold turkey
yeah others are saying well I'm gonna
cut down by 50% yeah yeah and that is a
very conscious very impactful choice
exactly when it's done at scale yeah
that's a Lex and I have definitely been
doing that this just being not
especially carnivorous mm-hm as a
decently what decently put way to say it
so you mentioned yet like Cargill and
Tyson they're yeah they're going deep
into their there they're investing and
that's a it's a big deal
okay so this is an interesting one we
should talk about this
Kanna ku yes yeah so yeah tell us about
this Oh what's his name oh gosh gosh is
the founder on our shoes such a cool guy
yeah I'm his and yeah so what is this
neurobiology mixed with synthetic
technology and silicon and what is what
is how to neuro encoded chips yeah what
those I mean the vision is all admit
even you know beyond my expertise in
many ways it's it's really out there but
basically if we you know think about our
brains and these vast and neural
networks um they're super computers when
you use them to the full extent they're
able to do things that even our best
technology can't so right now we're
using silicon to do computation I you
know in the conic who is aiming to
change the paradigm to using biology our
neurons to do so so they're you know
taking neurons and stabilizing them on a
chip making an environment outside of
the body where they can survive and then
training them to do different functions
whoa so right now you know an early
function is to basically train them to
be like a nose to detect things in the
air volatile compounds so there are
these um g-protein coupled receptors
GPCR is what they're called in our noses
in a dog's nose for example that are
picking up molecules in the air that is
causing odor and we have this big
library of knowledge and you can train
these neurons that are on a chip to
express different receptors for
different functions so you could imagine
instead of a dog doing bomb sniffing you
train basically a chip that has neurons
and you know something to read the
signal off of the neurons and then it
goes Bluetooth to a central database to
you know be able to detect neuron or
detect explosives yeah so one of the
demos he did I think roughly two years
ago when he finished Indy bio was
putting this nose essentially on a drone
and it would go up a chemical gradient
in the air
to hover above a landmine oh well rather
than people going out there yeah you
have this drone that can detect you know
parts-per-million yeah yeah of a
chemical explosive Wow
or for healthcare purposes people who
have type 1 diabetes there's a really
dangerous condition called eto acidosis
yeah which you can detect through fruity
breath is oftentimes an early you know
way of knowing it but even before it's
detectable to our nose there are a few
different compounds in the air that you
have a very sensitive monitor could
detect that so that's one example in
healthcare there's you know theories
aren't other disease you can sense
pretty early whoa mm-hmm and that is
just step number one yeah this is with a
small amount of neurons where together
the greater amount of neurons you get
the more complexity and have them do
this with like a hundred neurons or a
thousand neurons or how much is this
first step with the first step is under
100 100 and because you listed you
listed the sensing of parts per million
of chemicals or for land mines or maybe
for
this actually reminds me of Frey who
work oh combine spiral yeah yeah yeah I
loved working with him he's such a good
guy but that reminds me a lot of that
which is again being able to detect a
very small amount of of a gas leak
occurring for for a company like PG&E so
so interesting so what what animal do we
take neurons from what nervous system do
we take them from to put it on that chip
I think it depends so I know dogs are
one easy example for and from what I
understand these are you know large
libraries we express these dogs will
express them I think the concentrations
that they are expressed that is
different and these sensitivity is
different so it's how you train the
neurons and the receptors so I'm not
sure if those are a matter of these are
dog ones versus human ones though I
imagine there is some picking and
choosing but it depends on what you're
going for we can probably detect certain
things just much less sensitively than
dogs and maybe that's due to the
sensitivity of the receptors but also it
could be the amount that we have as well
and then the neurons work on silicon
they work on it yet they work cohesively
as one unit
yeah so you're putting it in and there's
a this is a lot of it is around you know
the discovery that they've made to put
it in these conditions and keep it the
right pH the right nutrients right
environment basically though how do they
stay alive yeah there's a limited time
frame but oh they do it's not indefinite
but even you know keeping with two
months is a quite a technical
achievement achieve me
and soon to be a thousand or a million
hundred million who want to get their
deals like I don't even have any idea
what the applications start it could so
then it would basically be like taking
and making a human brain in that
environment and then being able to use a
human brain for computational power
that's a vision I think at the high end
you know it's an unanswered question of
how do you if you put a million neurons
wired together how do you what is the
training mechanism to do more complex
tasks like a self-driving car so you get
a thousand neurons together it's not
enough to train it in some way to detect
the environment yeah I'm not sure it's
not a question that yeah I think we have
answered yet there's a lot of unexplored
frontiers here
what we can leverage all this power to
do and and as we go and get to that
point we can then figure out how many
exact neurons it takes to do these
different processes so so interesting
[Music]
okay because there's is it 86 billion
neurons in the brain is that the number
I think so yeah yeah I think so um
because I wonder how many then are would
need to be used for these complex tasks
or even simple ones what is it Ryan
Bethencourt taught me that there's like
10 or something or 40 neurons and a fly
something really small right something
of the density yeah I don't know the
exact number it's yeah much much smaller
these you know and they're doing really
complex tasks yeah
detecting sensing the environment so
yeah so there's still a lot to be
explored around how do we have these
neurons do all these functions yeah them
can't believe something with that small
of an amount of neurons can do so many
of the crazy things that the Y does
react to the environment yes a dynamic
way
yeah okay so gosh Connor who's so cool
be good to get a shun alright so I
actually saw this one on your profile
recently synth X is that how you say it
since that yeah synth X yeah yeah so
what is the what is what are we talking
about with targeted therapeutics what
does this mean
you come from a pharmacy background so
you can give us a good understanding of
this as well yeah so it's it's changing
a paradigm of where the where the drugs
are working
so right now oftentimes most drugs with
some exception are small molecules so
use very small precise molecules that
fit into a binding pocket on a much
larger structure called a protein what
proteins also interact in a huge number
of ways that is a you know a tiny
molecule can't block these large
structures from touching each other so
syntax is working on a class of
therapeutic called peptides which are
these much larger interfaces that if you
have these two proteins coming together
it can go in and block them from ever
actually being able to function there's
a lot of pathways and cancer and other
diseases that are mediated by these
protein protein interactions so it's a
much more difficult drug to make so it's
one thing to go from just finding a
peptide in the lab to making it
something that can be injected soluble
in the human body non-toxic targeted to
the right protein structure so yeah so
that's what they're working on is a new
system to actually make peptide
therapeutics and then make them stable
and druggable in the human body
let's wander down this the ethics and
the philosophy of this and the
biotechnology there's just a little bit
more what is going on with so many
different ways to solve problems we have
so many different ways that we can solve
these problems and it seems like let's
take an example of a human body I've
talked about this before
and I've gotten answers from people
before that say that there's no one you
know golden way to figure it out and I
wonder what your perspective is on it
because we have this human body and so
many people like opportu Grand Union are
focused on figuring out how to provide
the option for people to live longer if
they want and to stay healthy longer so
as we figure out how to do that is it
could there be just you one best way to
figure out how to do that versus like
you just described there's that's only
one of probably hundreds or thousands of
ways that people are exploring how to be
live healthier hmm yeah whatever
it could there be that one best way to
live healthier and what would that be
okay what would it be if I had that
question I have you know the most
miraculous infomercial in the world it's
a great question there's a couple you
know more nuance to doing up questions
that you can go down there
no one is we're looking at lifespan
which is total number of years versus
health span you know is someone getting
to 150 but they've eaten your restricted
calories every day of their life been
kind of unable to enjoy you know this
amazing world we have or does someone
reach 80 at a really phenomenal function
for 99 percent of that time mmm I think
to exceptionally different questions
right now and the longevity is part of
it which is just getting more years
behind that I think is something that
would take out you know people doing a
lifetime of research and not having a
solid answer it's a little bit I think
beyond my knowledge I think we've seen
you know methods work in mice in small
small C elegans and other microorganisms
multi-celled organisms calorie
restriction being a big one yeah it is
I'm actually fasting right now nice my
second day of fasting how long are you
going
probably the full second day and maybe
part of the third day it will figure it
out nice I think fasting is one of those
really fascinating areas when it comes
to when you're young and then especially
as you get older I'm keeping a blood
sugar in check I think people have
interesting theories around it purging
precancerous cells
yeah which we always have for me in our
body and we'll just cleanse again so to
speak yeah a toff AG is you know what is
it Hoffa G again tava G is basically
cell death inducing
non like someone you have a trauma like
a cut or a big bruise it's cell death
that it wasn't a plan by the body so to
speak ha ha but it you know esophageal
cell death cell clean-out so when you're
restricting calories cells are they have
time and this is kind of what the
theories of the mechanism are actually
clearing out debris and old proteins and
recycling a lot to run much more
efficiently mmm because they're not you
know mired in the process of digestion
mm-hmm I think it's one of those that
it's you know it's very difficult to
have a randomized control trial that
goes for the span of a human life but
you know people on the edge of
performance and who have severe disease
are experimenting with these things yeah
so ok so you think that there's there's
possibly these it's possible that there
is something that could be that golden
thing for us to tweak we just need the
little tweaks along the way tweaking our
path their pathways of DNA damage and
DNA yeah exactly so that might be the
like number one way does that seems like
what Audrey is kind of what a lot of
these yeah yeah ageing researchers are
ya looking at I think that that might be
the golden one it might be at least
until we get to a point where we can do
whatever you want with your
consciousness and uploading your brain
yeah wherever you want yeah exactly so
these little tweaks along the way cuz
you know you guys totally know you feel
so much different when you're 13 and 18
than you do when you're at 40 feel
completely different you know your
hearts beat so many more times your
backs been hurt so many more times so
yeah
so how can we do these tweaks along the
way to to live healthy to feel like a 13
or an 18 year old for as long as we want
and to not have our parents died of
cancer or Alzheimer's or whatever okay
so let's let's talk a bit about the the
future ethical conversations that we are
gonna have about genetic engineering
because I I hope that nd bio from like
these like high-level conversations that
you guys are having there's at least
some sort of uh at least a care or a
desire to have the tougher conversations
about what do we think about genetic
engineering applied to exacerbating
wealth inequality yeah it seems to be
one of the top things that's been coming
back to me is that eight people own as
much wealth as four billion on the
bottom side of things and they're
getting access to nanotech gene
engineering neural laces colonizing
space I mean it's it's getting a gap
widening yeah in many senses but you
know Steven Pinker just writes about how
oh the bottom is coming up you know
which is great like you're right but the
bottom is coming up but at the same time
they don't have at the bottom four
billion barely have access to a
smartphone for now let alone an AI that
is running around and making people
money or doing whatever so
where are how many conversations is like
indie bio having and what are you what
are maybe your perspectives on what
genetic engineering can do because of
course akin genetic engineer await
disease for people to eradicate
suffering which is amazing we definitely
want that but then there's augmenting
people's intelligence or metabolism etc
all these yeah it's it's really
interesting because it's a conversation
we have it's certainly not something
that is fundable or that we are funding
we're looking at eliminating disease
like the company I mentioned before one
mutation one fix to get rid of severe
suffering when it comes to those you
know much more gray lines ethical
questions it and we debate and like many
people there's no concise answer where
where does the line end between ending
suffering and going into something that
doesn't you know it's only given access
to a small percentage I think
intelligence you know we have some
indicators of certain genes that will
make people you know perform better be a
little bit smarter things like that
there's a huge cluster of interaction so
we don't yet understand but I think it's
it's a very real question how do we make
sure that everyone gets access to these
because we know we haven't solved so
much around education so much around
health and access to to good food good
water these basic questions but yeah
we're kind of jumping over them to get
to something that's for just a small
percentage of people yeah that's a crazy
thought right there that's a really
important one to think about the
potential for billion might not have
access to clean water and some cases and
clean food in some cases shelter in some
cases the basic physiological needs yet
we're going you know already dope but
that's also at the same time people talk
about not wanting to impede the progress
of capitalism and innovation so there's
there's I would say the the truth is
always in the middle there yeah yeah
I think I think there's no black and
white here yes it's certainly not a bad
thing to be pushing humanity forward and
that's pushing my unlock fundamental
technology that will maybe make access
to water much much easier yes cheaper
exactly so there's a balance I think
it's people keeping perspective and
keeping you know focus on maybe multiple
things at times you know Bill Gates for
example yeah it's a great example of
someone who's doing a ton to alleviate
suffering yes of the bottom billion
bottom two billion yeah also looking at
frontier technology some people who have
access to both are actually using the
resources in a wise way he's a really
good pull yeah as much as he's
alleviating like polio malaria he's also
working on AI technology it's very
interesting yeah yeah and one thing to
kind of circle back to long before
around giving tools to more and more
people and more and more places like
when we have people who are building
companies and creating technology not
just in Boston San Francisco you know
London he's you know large hubs
Singapore of a biotech and tech
innovation but people who are in labs
and you know in Africa or in other
places in Southeast Asia their salt or
Latin America we're seeing these people
who are solving no problems that are
very relevant to them that they see that
we don't because we're here we have
access exactly they're seeing what's
different in their world exactly they're
creating new solutions at you know being
in the California San Francisco bubble
we don't experience all the time yeah so
we have to also think about how do we
give resources and power them that's why
you know with Indy bio we don't just
fund Bay Area company for our us-based
companies exactly help help people
everywhere yeah
I mean you're nailing it so well I was
when we were talking to John Peterson
about this we were discussing the
importance of potentially increasing
creative output or increasing bottom
line of companies by bringing in
different people from around the world
to actually have the conversations
because they're bringing in different
perspectives from outside of the Bay
Area or outside of the United States and
that's adding so much to to innovation
creativity in my opinion we need to do
of course more longitudinal studies
about this and get some more literature
on it but it could potentially be very
very beneficial to have a woman sitting
on the board of the company because then
she can provide a feminine a diverse
perspective or somebody that's
neurodiverse or someone that's a person
of color in the US or maybe a US person
in China or in Latin it cetera so okay
now I'll say yeah go ahead bring them
here to give them tools and education
and see what's available but also it's
important to to venture out into a world
and to go to these countries all over ya
and see what is life like what are the
things we take for granted and have
access to every day that maybe they
don't and how does that affect our
decision-making
yeah I'm optimistic about being able to
figure it out together I think there's
this new era of humanity and awareness
that's being ushered in slowly and I
think that that optimistic feeling that
I have about it is going to solve some
of these big
things that we think might be a problem
in the future such as wealth inequality
all right
so we hit some of the ethics of genetic
engineering glitz I actually really
wanted to talk about this with you for
at least a little bit because it seems
like we're pretty close
what are the companies that you guys
have funded that are working on growing
organs and replacing organs in the body
is it working novo or no is that one of
our company yeah that's that is not as
enough so we the whole stem cell cell
therapy regenerative medicine space is
one we're super interested in and moving
into more and more to that that came
through a new bio a little while ago
that I think we're really interesting
one is a called bio aesthetics they are
actually for women who get mastectomy
where they have breast cancer and guess
right
if you get their breast cut off they're
actually regrowing the nipple areola
complex yeah which we can't currently do
that's so interesting it's right right
there that's high aesthetics by
aesthetics yeah so taking tissue from
donors cadavers mm-hmm D cellular izing
it so you just leave the the collagen
kind of scaffolding then you put it on a
patient their own selves on migrate into
into the scaffold to make a native
living tissue yeah that's a very clever
approach by them because if you're
looking at we want to start with
regrowing a kidney for example a much
more complex structure you also have to
get it into the body as opposed to
something outside so there's a lot a lot
more time to market because of all the
complexity of the biology so a nipple is
a one very impactful because there are
patients there's studies of it
people quality of life differences
people willing to get the life-saving
procedure sometimes of a mastectomy
definitely depression and other things
that come with it yeah so there's a huge
impact injustice seemingly very small
piece of the body
the other one that has two amazing
founders I'm Melanie and Noel is called
prelate biologics they're actually doing
3d bioprinting using lasers which is a
totally different approach because
everyone has talked about 3d printing
organs for a while but it's it's
incredibly difficult to print those
small structures you know the very small
micro vasculature the blood vessels
right now to get to that resolution and
normal 3d printer just can't go that
small they're actually using lasers so
where the two beams of light intersect
in a collagen bath they're polymerizing
collagen it's actually making the
structure that would be kind of the what
these cells of a lung for example a part
of and rest on there using lasers in the
collagen bath to organize the way that
the organ is grown to organize the
structure of the collagen structure the
kind of skeleton in a manner of speaking
of an organ then there's cells that are
seeding on top of them okay the actual
stem cells okay so they're solving the
problem of printing micro vasculature
and they micro vasculature so some of
the proof of concepts which were really
impressive one they printed a lymph node
which is part of our immune system to
make human antibodies and they
challenged it Masika and saw Muzyka
antibodies coming out mm-hmm so showing
it was actually functional they also
printed
and a blood vessel they put red dye in
so the liquid and saw that it actually
contained a liquid without leaking
that's showing that it's binding at a
very cellular level to make functional
cell walls which is really important to
eventually build an organ so that the
end goal is being able to print kidneys
lungs yep all these major organs that we
need but starting at a much smaller
level to show proof of concept and next
up is attempting to do beta cells which
are the insulin producing cells of
diabetics don't have and that I think
their next milestone is putting them
into a mouse to see if it's actually
taking the mouse is accepting the or the
cells and then hopefully producing
insulin with it
Wow yeah look all the way from
mastectomy x' and nipples to to the
laser printing of organs yeah in damn
and that's super awesome
and it's such a vital part about where
we're going it's definitely another one
of those parts of who can afford this
technology and also when going back to
the the longevity question you had
before often times you know when people
die it's you know one massive organ
failure that leads to a systemic failure
so if you can yeah get on top of that
early yeah and give people new fresh
like very capable organs exhibit that
could likely increased lifespan out
imagine yeah especially when there's
oftentimes no option or a long donor
waitlist that people have to go through
yeah yeah the
the actual full scan of the body to be
able to know what's going on with it is
when I think we're not quite there yet
to know every biometric and when
something's about to go wrong to go in
and prevent it from going wrong that
will be an interesting point in human
bio technology when we get there just to
be able to get full readout of what's
going on on you internally that we
obviously have no freaking I know idea
yeah just like a little bit of pain here
is it my kidney or is it like my ABS
hurting from yesterday is it a tumor who
knows that yeah yet being able to detect
biomarkers you know people are looking
at how do you implant something that
could be monitoring biomarkers all the
time it's a huge challenge I haven't
seen anyone that has made that happen
I think of the intermediate from now
until then there's at least making blood
testing much more you know democratize
much cheaper yeah and done much more
frequently exactly right now rather than
once a year maybe eight yeah yeah if you
have there's company and cheap enough
and yeah working on single single drop
you diagnostics and exactly send it send
it on in yeah mm-hmm and that'll be an
earth a way to start getting on top of
it early and also seeing much more
active trends and what's happening in
your body whether you're healthy or in
response to drug therapy yeah yeah yeah
all those that's so good yeah both of
those cases and I totally would love
that actually it seems like proteomics
is the more dynamic and shifting way to
understand like that single drop of
blood sending that off seems way more
than the whole mapping of the genome
that doesn't change as much genomics
don't change as much as proteomics are
much more dynamic yeah exactly so you
know what's happening what is the
difference between in you know your skin
and a kidney
that's expression of DNA into RNA and
then proteins to to build the structure
so each of these have different parts of
your genetic code that are being
activated to do different functions
create different structures and make you
function again very dynamic yeah looking
at epigenetic changes so how our
environment or lifespan is changing how
DNA is expressed as well
easy how quickly cultural evolution
changes compared to biological evolution
mm-hmm just that is so fast changing and
it affect in the way that it affects us
versus the way that we biologically
evolved how could we adapt to this
environment yeah yeah the rate that it's
changing it's a huge question if there
yeah our body's having on the health
side adapted to having sugar and food
available all the time oh yeah on the
mental health side a very different
world where addiction being being being
being also even how we live whether
we're in communities or alone or you
know in one apartment in a box full of a
thousand other boxes yeah very different
than no 500 years ago
even you know and in 100 years it's hard
to predict
what we'll be doing megacities owns all
of these little boxes hmm and one of my
buddies is working on the Eco village
out outside of Chicago it's all
sustainable you're living out and about
you can go to tune in when you want to
back out into the metropolis you know
what I mean it's good to have a little
balance of that out in California maybe
we can have one of these a little eco
villages as well so you know and go
there and come back into the loop these
boxed up condos yeah you're right all
these different cultural evolutions
we're not there just so fast and there's
changing so quickly and I was this
biological being adapting to those yeah
the smaller spaces the ding ding ding
ding dings and you bring up a good one
the the sugar and the food the constant
yeah and I always mention this to people
but and actually Nassim Taleb has been
further pushing it through me as well
The Linde affect just how long things
have been around for example like the
wheel where the hub that holds water
Earl interesting yeah that that that
that is equivalent to the amount of life
that it will have from this present
moment on so the we will be around a lot
longer in this and this couple be around
a lot longer versus something like
snapchat that was invented a couple
years ago might only be around for a
couple more years so things that have a
shorter have had a shorter lifespan will
probably have a shorter lifespan in the
future things I have all much longer
legs now I'll likely have a much longer
lifespan
that I'm totally I'm having so many more
conversations about mimetics rather than
genetics interestingly enough like if
you can plant a seed in the minds of a
couple million people or even a billion
people around the world to care more
about science and technology and the
future of working together as a cohesive
planet we don't need to discover aliens
to figure out we're all one tribe we can
we can figure that out together first
but if you plant that idea the whole
cultural dissemination of that idea to
people that might be much more powerful
than focusing on birthing a child into
the world and focusing all of your
attention on the child and driving it
the child that's a crazy new thought my
thing very true what is it what is the
impact of your life and when you you
know expand the bubble for someone does
it can it ever shrink back to what it
was before so if you give these ideas
around how much someone's capable of
whether it's through education whether
it caring for others acting altruistic
thinking beyond themselves can they ever
go back to to their previous selves I
don't very a very interesting question
yeah think so Benson and that's the
expansion of the mind to new dimensions
once I tell you once I learned about
this code of life and understanding it
in that way
the HTC's in G isn't being able to tweak
it for all these different purposes for
the health and longevity for our food
systems for all these crazy ways you
know my plane C never went back
ever yeah that's only one of many of
these interdisciplinary ways to
understand our world again remember that
will cosmic perspective and the whole
molecular DNA perspective of the humans
in the middle once you get that again
it's you can't go back so how do we
plant these okay let's get let's venture
into this question how do we maximize
human
ooh that's an amazing question it's it's
fascinating I think it's such a
important question of our time when we
look at how society is changing the
utility quote-unquote of individuals
work our schools are built on a
different society a factory mentality
whereas now we get rid of the a lot of
the manual labor and we free up human
creativity I think it certainly starts
young giving giving kids more more tools
more more varied input letting them kind
of guide their own paths a bit there's
you know Khan School and these other
experimental schools I think are really
letting kids go into their passions and
find passions more and when you create
kind of that again where you expand
their bubble into that something they
want to do that's how they live it will
probably just continue expanding but
it's good there's you know that's again
that's here in a in a society that has
access to food water a roof energy in
other places we have to you know give
people all those foundational tools to
have their needs taken care of and have
their time taken care of to then focus
on solving greater community problems
and from the community's thinking
outward and outward
I think people when given the the
knowledge the motivation and the tools
to do it
tend to focus on altruism I think it's
I'm you know maybe it's my naive part of
the view of the world but it I hope so
again with Jordan we were talking about
people that become more competent
typically want to help other people more
competent you are typically the more you
understand that it's very important to
help other people in the world
I like how you bring up education as
kind of fundamental understanding of
maximizing potential I completely agree
with you and there is this myriad of new
ways that we are exploring how to
educate young people into the world I
like to always bring it to
the parent the parent of the child not
as the only educator but if you are
birthing a child into this world it is
your responsibility to educate that
child about the world that they live in
their lay up yeah do just don't just
drop off the heaters and hope that it
goes well it's up to you yeah and at
that point you know you'll end up bill
becoming a better friend with that child
as well I'm they'll treating more like a
mentor and a teacher as well as a parent
both and I you know I don't have kids so
it's a I'm not speaking from experience
I
I would imagine also when he maybe have
parents I do have parents yeah a good
catch
when you look at you know mirror neurons
how when we see something we we act on
it and try and replicate it especially
at a young age where we don't have you
know a lot of constraints and good and
bad being taught what we what we do
other people see and they they do as
well that's why I think you mentioned
before were smiling more people there
are mirror neurons turning on and those
and endorphins start flowing and they're
in a better mood of the rest of the day
so you have impact by your actions by
your example and how you each moment is
an opportunity to affect someone in a
positive way or a negative way and
that's something you have hundreds of
thousands of chances every single day to
steer yourself and someone else I look
more positive in course of action
exactly yeah
they even down to the present moment
level every single day just smile äj--
yeah and steering people down better
courses so it's good that that's a
really awesome answer for maximizing
potential how about we talked about this
a little bit earlier but the global
ruling elite do you think that one
exists I can't say put a lot of time
into worrying about it because it feels
a bit beyond my means to act I tend to
again this is based off him no not much
research or thought on the Illuminati or
what not uh I tend to not not think
about that I think there are certainly
circles of influence where ya know the
people who are running you know large
companies you know large parts of the
world there's who are they communicating
with who are they around yeah so whether
it's an organized or not organized
circle so to speak ideas are coming from
a certain subset of the population which
in a sense kind of creates that maybe
unintentionally yeah
maybe unintentional there work out
putting this on the internet so whatever
we say yeah cuz out there maybe they did
definitely know you that's a good way to
put it the circle of who's controlling
the US government who's controlling
Google who's controlling China who's
controlling all these different entities
how they're communicating with one
another to build the world and I think
they definitely know that they're
influencing billions of people's lives
it's hard not to yeah yeah yeah you know
there's the saying you know you're the
average of the peer group you surround
yourself with so these people are all
creating massive gravitational pull
exactly towards ideas or ways of being
exactly yeah yeah that's so crucial I'm
glad you brought that up because you
gotta surround ourselves with really
smart people that are impacting the
world that are doing again they seem to
have supplanted skin in the game into my
mind I'm gotta surround yourself with
doers people that have actual skin in
the game he always talks about I don't
care what you say you have in your
portfolio I care about looking at your
actual portfolio and seeing what you
actually
have and that's that's the same thing
with but even the way that you could
talk about wanting to change the world
that biotech I want to change it in this
way I wanna change that way yeah but
what 81 companies do you have you
actually accelerated this is that kind
of stuff and so doing is crucial in this
process okay let's do a couple of these
last thoughts let's go with do you think
we're alone in the cosmos really doubt
it again not a physicist astronomer or
anything like that but what do you think
of the vastness of our universe like
it's hard for me to imagine that and for
us yeah we've expanded our sphere of the
earth of the center of the universe the
Sun is and now you know there's much
much beyond us yeah and no doubt about
that yeah Ron Alex's answer I doubt it
yeah I like how quick yeah quick and
powerful that was okay and then our we
in a computer simulation
so I'm certainly not a programmer an AI
guy VR guy
those aren't those are fascinating areas
but the amount of time to have I think a
enough knowledge to have a strong
opinion is I don't feel like I have it
again I go back to almost in a sense not
worrying about it because you know it's
something I can't control when it comes
to that theory and I I feel weather
delusional or not that I have control of
my actions every day so focusing on what
am i doing now what how am i impacting
the world and changing my behavior it's
much more important to me than
theorizing on something that I just I
don't know how you have any way of
confirming denying or impacting that so
I'm gonna go with no because I like to
keep my illusion of some control on my
life whether or not I'm I am completely
delusional there I love your you know
your humility is so honorable just to
preface every single one of these
questions with like hey I'm not you know
I'm totally in biotech I'm not a
physicist and not in all these spaces
but that's why we there's so much
complexity out there there is be a
master of all it's very difficult and
that's why having a lot of breadth but
not a lot of depth in all of those
fields you know that's why I try and
understand biotechnology from at least
the high level like ten thousand foot
view but I don't get any of the you know
RNA still don't know how to explain RNA
you know things like that so with in
biotech I think there's a or health
medicine science it was like the you
know bench top early research of the
tools that picks and shovels the
genomics there's a you know clinical
side which is more where I come from
like how is this on a systems level
affecting someone there's a huge breadth
even in biotech like you know there are
people that very few people who are I
would say close to masters of both you
so then to go venture beyond that is
just another grant challenge mm-hmm and
this is why we bring people onto the
show that are very smart like yourself
eager to talk a lot about biotech and
what the future of that looks like and
then we run you through a couple
questions that are definitely in
different field of expertise and we get
to hear you know your perspective about
those things as well because it's good
to like you said it's good to know at
least the vastness of the cosmos and
understanding that yeah I doubt it and
then if we do doubt it then the
likelihood that there are other people
you know roaming around that have
colonized their star systems and stuff
like that are could potentially have
figured out how to simulate a unit and
it might be interesting to think about
so I like how you brought up that you
you're thinking about every single day
how to become better yourself because
it's something that you can control how
to become better so I like that I like
that focus I think that's really crucial
and important for other people to hear
well thank you yeah okay what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
no the question
[Music]
then go back I think I'm thinking of a
most beautiful place I've seen I think
like going back to I think probably most
beautiful place I I've seen with my my
own eyes has been Costa Rica I think of
all the places I've traveled seeing the
jungle and how it merges right and right
into the ocean yeah is a really
inspiring and again connect me back to
before like society evolving faster than
biology like yeah that's I think for
humans why we go on vacation to go camp
in the middle of nowhere away from all
of our convenience is a modern life
because there's something just uniquely
amazing and kind of fulfilling about
being in those environments yeah I love
how you describe the jungle ending at
the ocean I haven't been to a place like
that it sounds so amazing I think the
closest I've been to something like
that's like Muir Woods in Stinson Beach
you know you got to drive a little bit
it's pretty blessed in California pretty
blessed yeah yeah what we have but that
crystal clear like blue water beach and
then just freakin massive trees right
entering into yeah jungle all right so
that's pretty pretty good maybe
something that you're most interested in
or looking forward to in biotechnology
ooh I have like a couple different
things running through my head I think
something I'm really excited about tying
biotech and medicine actually which are
very interrelated in many ways is a
switch of looking at most diseases as
metabolic disease I think it's something
that gets talked about to some extent
but we don't fully understand the the
implications of that whether it's things
like diabetes and you know
cardiovascular disease which are very
obvious tied to diet a lifestyle so
looking at you know people who have a
lot of theories around Alzheimer's and
cancer as driven by dysfunctional
metabolism I think when we start looking
at that we're gonna start seeing how how
do we for a whole life all of our
choices are acting and changing that so
yeah whether it's things like the
ketogenic diet to control diabetes I'm
fasting for cancer yeah we're gonna see
more and more things around food food as
medicine yeah because we're taking drugs
which are foreign substances to
influence some processes in our body and
food if you think about it yeah
foreign substance that is altering our
metabolism our hormones
neurotransmitters put it yeah so I think
that's a frontier of medicine that
people are gonna be looking at more and
more so the metabolism we use that as
our ability to take in food use that as
energy and process at to empower our
body's heart to be and brain to function
metabolism functioning you described the
Met you describe metabolism being a
direct potential effector of things like
cancer and Alzheimer's heart disease so
you want to understand better how the
metabolism relates to disease developing
pathology
yeah so I mean there are theories around
Alzheimer's being essentially type 3
diabetes or uncontrolled blood sugar is
actually affecting our neurons our work
one controlled blood sugar and causing
diabetes neuro inflammation causing
neuro inflammation ha ha and in cancer
you know a lot of you know disbalances
and you know cancer you know a lot of
people have also talked about whether
it's what other main nutrients driving
cancer whether it's for certain
conditions fasting seems to be helping
because you're taking away sugar as a
fuel source yeah I mean there's other
specific amino acids that cancels might
preferentially use have certain pathways
of creating energy or shut down they
switch to other pathways so different if
you restrict certain amino acids there
are theories around being able to halt
or be an adjuvant to chemotherapy to
stop cancer growth yeah so I think you
know it's really seeing food as medicine
and these nutrients to how how
efficiently our body is operating the
side effects of that if you check out
Alex's Instagram account you'll see the
way we'll put the link in the bio your
plates that you design those are totally
joke central so they are completely a
hundred percent yes 100 percent
yeah I thought that you worked over my
meals I thought you were actually eating
just like a little bit of vegetable and
a little bit of I thought you were
actually only eating that much food
because you were calorically restricting
yourself so I do have not entirely but
mostly plant-based diet really heavy on
vegetables and fruit with some meat some
other protein sources yeah seafood eggs
some extent yeah and then when it comes
to calorie restriction definitely
looking at maybe fasting a couple days
of the month if there was a period of
time where intermittent fasting was a
regular part of my routine yeah I found
that especially when I was actually in
grad school worked really well with my
schedules yeah
only one meal at some point one day
maybe two meals evening like that yeah
spaced like six hours apart or something
yeah now I think it's looking at having
flexibility and and diet to be have
enough breadth of knowledge and ways to
live that you'll have to be stuck and
obsessively eating you know ketogenic
all fat
no no sugar at times being able to go
the other way at times fasting at times
not so I know man you know me I'm like
cold turkey you like I love that kind of
stuff but it's but it becomes like
Jinyan says you need a bag of Doritos
every once in a while or you know a
little french fries from McDonald's
every once in a while yeah exactly to
just push the weeble wobble in the
different directions z-axis as well all
the freaking accesses well we have you
know a long life so having do you want a
way of living that's sustainable for 80
years or one that after a month you're
you're savvy yeah so yeah looking at I
think these are very small cumulative
actions and none of them are
catastrophic
none of them are miraculous so to speak
so the thing that you're mostly in
forward to is better understanding food
as medicine I think or nutrition in
general is an area and yeah integrating
that and lifestyle into how we work with
patients how we educate people from a
young age how do we created an
environment that's going back to human
flourishing people are you know in a
healthy state they're energized or
inspired to do great work and help other
people yeah Helly yes all about that
this is why we're friends this is why
you come on our podcast this is why we
talk about these things around what did
you like most about the biotechnology
and understanding the code of life
[Music]
he's done no he's not on his headphones
no what do you think we are right now
Ron needs lunch yeah yeah we need all
this food talk yeah I love the food talk
he's like Alan's fasting nah it's okay
we'll get you some food right yeah yeah
I'm not so awesome everyone thanks for
tuning in to simulation series vodcast
with Alex couple yeah this has been an
absolute blast Thank You Alan ventured
down so many great conversations about
biotech and the code of life and how
it's impacting our future we'll put your
links we already have the indie bio link
and the bio will throw in your Twitter
Instagram throw in a couple both I'm not
a big social media guy so we'll put it
to indie BIOS then better indie bio tags
me and stuff so that's why I'm I'm still
active on there yeah and so we'll throw
some links in the bio check them out and
guys at home if you guys had a good time
if you think this is useful for you in
some way give it a share with other
people like comment subscribe we'll be
producing more content soon if you want
to join in the conversation become a
patron we have a patreon link in the bio
we enable you to have conversations with
our guest priority and asking questions
priority and exclusive content priority
and live event information so check us
out on patreon huge thanks to Ron Vargas
behind there TriCaster our director and
producer doing an amazing job huge
thanks to Dulce and the river Studios
family for hosting us at their venue and
all their links are in the bio as well
thanks Alex it's been an absolute blast
and we'll catch you guys soon
cool thanks Alan whoo
[Music]